você está feliz quando pensa nesta
pergunta você provavelmente cria uma
fórmula de felicidade em sua cabeça adicionando
vários aspectos de sua vida, como
saúde familiar ambiente vida social
hobbies e a lista continua com todos
os componentes razoáveis que realmente
impactam significativamente  seus
níveis de felicidade, mas e a beleza em
que você não pensou nisso, e se eu lhe dissesse
que a beleza pode afetar muito ou até mesmo
determinar inteiramente o quão feliz você é
essa beleza pode ser o componente chave
que impulsiona todos os outros quantos de vocês
consideram  vocês lindas mãos para cima
vamos lá eu quero ver o amor próprio sim
tire as mãos de todos mãos para cima cabeça para cima sim
mãos para cima ok ótimo eu vejo algumas mãos levantadas
mantenham-nas levantadas por um minuto e eu espero que vocês
não se importem mas eu vou  para dizer a todos
vocês porque aos olhos de uma nação inteira
você não é bonito
uma vez eu fiquei uma característica que não se
aplica a você abaixe suas mãos
vamos ver quem sobrevive primeiro se você
não tem olhos grandes com faça  pálpebras dobradas
mãos para baixo se você não tiver um
nariz alto e pequeno mãos para baixo
se você não tiver um maxilar em forma de V afiado
mãos para baixo se você não tiver pele clara e pálida
mãos para baixo se você não tiver
sob os olhos  mãos gordas temos
alguém sobrando parabéns Coréia
te acha linda sim whoo
bem vindo a Coréia do Sul um país conhecido
por suas iguarias como kimchi Peru Kogi
e peeping bub
um país caracterizado pelo kpop
representado por estrelas como BTS desde que eu não
importa o quão maravilhoso  não estou
aqui para falar sobre isso estou aqui para
falar sobre o lado feio da Coréia o lado que
gostamos de manter para nós mesmos então o que é
esse lado feio somos a
capital da cirurgia plástica do mundo com
mais procedimentos estéticos feitos por  capita,
estima-se que 50% das mulheres coreanas na
faixa dos 20 anos e 20% das mulheres coreanas de qualquer idade vão à faca, enquanto, em
comparação, 0,05% das
mulheres americanas fazem cirurgia plástica, nossa
indústria de cirurgia plástica é tão rica e tão
avançada que atrai  cts estrangeiros à
procura de uma visita médica entre
janeiro e dezembro de 2014 o
Ministério da Saúde e Bem-Estar da Coréia estima
que 107 milhões de dólares em receita foram
gerados exclusivamente por turistas
que fizeram cirurgia plástica na Coréia para não esquecer que também temos uma indústria de cosméticos em expansão
muitos de vocês  aqui hoje pode estar
familiarizado com k-beauty, que
recentemente ganhou popularidade através de
suas máscaras faciais agudas e ótimos
produtos para a pele, de acordo com a
administração de comércio internacional dos EUA, a partir de
2016, o mercado de cosméticos coreano
é estimado em 7,1 bilhões de
dólares, tornando-o o  oitavo maior
mercado de cosméticos do mundo,
representando 3% do mercado global,
bastante impressionante para um país pequeno, se
você me perguntar, essa onda esmagadora e
chocante de estatísticas que acabei de
atingir pode ser amplamente contribuída e
creditada ao fato de que na Coréia
beleza significa  felicidade beleza significa mais
oportunidades beleza significa vantagens na
vida não hesitamos  t ao expressar
o fato de que ser mais bonita faz de você uma
pessoa mais agradável, sabemos que é
injusto e superficial e quase todos
nós odiamos isso, mas não importa o quão distorcido
seja um fato, você simplesmente não pode ser
bonito e feliz ao mesmo tempo  tempo, quero
dizer, não bonito e feliz ao mesmo
tempo, é porque a beleza é a chave
que o ajudará a fazer primeiras impressões mais positivas,
ter conexões sociais mais fortes,
abrir oportunidades de carreira,
dar-lhe uma voz mais alta para a sociedade e
apenas viver uma vida melhor em geral, isso
aspecto de sua sociedade é claramente e
excelentemente retratado através de um
programa de reforma coreano este programa foi ao ar por cinco
temporadas entre 2011 e 2016 e
não foi um programa de reforma comum
não foi uma reforma através de uma mudança
no estilo de cabelo ou um novo guarda-roupa  mas
sim uma reforma através de você adivinhou
cirurgia plástica procedimentos de cirurgia plástica gratuitos
feitos pelos melhores cirurgiões
do mercado seriam presenteados ao
participante escolhido e th  Esses participantes
competiriam pelo prêmio apresentando
suas histórias de vida terríveis e afortunadas
para eles essa reforma significava uma
vida diferente significava que seu marido traidor que
constantemente exigia o divórcio com parar de
ser infiel significava que eles ainda tinham
uma chance de realizar um sonho de toda a vida de
tornando-se comissária de bordo
o show filmou as vidas dos competidores
após a reforma e as promessas de
beleza foram mantidas seus problemas suas
lutas de vida desapareceram o marido traidor de
repente amou sua esposa e a
garota que era muito feia para sequer sonhar em
ser comissária de bordo e rolou  para
treinar este show agiu como um grupo de
salvadores trazendo os pobres feios
para uma vida melhor exclusiva
acessível apenas para os bonitos e este
show é uma prova registrada de que a
beleza realmente significa felicidade na Coréia que a
beleza é a chave para escapar de uma
vida insatisfatória e  a cirurgia plástica
é uma ferramenta disponível que se deve usar
ao máximo chocantemente isso u
foi o meu processo de pensamento exato durante um
curto período de tempo que morei na Coréia, eu tinha
entre 7 e 9 anos e me
mudei do exterior sem saber muito sobre
as normas e dinâmicas sociais coreanas, em
outras palavras, eu era uma ardósia limpa no meu
chegada eu estava matriculado em uma
escola pública localizada no coração de Seul e
com o passar do tempo eu naturalmente mudei
e fui moldado em uma típica criança sul-
coreana não houve resistência
a essa mudança porque eu não estava
ciente dessa ideia de que beleza  é a chave
para a fórmula da felicidade
me consumiu lenta e discretamente me consumiu
através de anúncios inteligentes nos
transportes públicos fizeram suas celebridades bonitas e bonitas
na TV e até mesmo através dos meus
colegas de escola primária eu
não tinha ideia de que pensar que beleza é igual a
felicidade não era normal  pensei
ter e o que me assusta é que eu não
acho que eu teria sido capaz de
perceber isso se eu não tivesse me mudado
porque toda a minha vida todo o meu mundo
mesmo quando criança  girava em torno dessa
ideia eu me via pensando
se compraria impulsivamente aquela
cola de pálpebra dupla no balcão da papelaria
imaginando como eu ficaria com uma
rinoplastia ou cirurgia de aparamento de mandíbula
imaginando se algum dia receberia
uma cirurgia plástica de presente para meus
parentes assim  uma garota no ensino
médio fez esses pensamentos cotidianos normais
para um aluno do ensino fundamental na minha
área e a configuração do tempo para não se
enganar Eu NÃO estou afirmando que ainda é
assim para alunos do ensino fundamental em
2018 Eu pessoalmente não saberia, no entanto,
minha falta  de conhecimento sobre os
alunos do ensino fundamental de hoje não invalida
o fato de que meus amigos do ensino fundamental
agora são adolescentes comprando maquiagem
e quantias em massa e traçando seus
planos futuros para fazer cirurgia plástica aos
16 anos eu já tenho um amigo
que fez dois grandes procedimentos
crianças como eu em um ponto
crescem cercadas por essas ideias nocivas
que influenciam seus processos de pensamento
fazendo-nos pensar que só podemos ser felizes se
fizermos uma cirurgia plástica e não
notarmos nada de errado com isso porque
fomos criados com ela nos moldou
naturalmente tornando-se parte de nós e
consumindo nossa imagem de felicidade a
questão aqui não é  que meus amigos estão
fazendo cirurgia plástica, se isso os
deixar mais confortáveis em sua própria pele
aumentar sua auto-estima, eles são compl
tamente livres para fazê-lo, em vez d
sso, o problema é que meus amigos são levad
s a fazê-lo, não por motivos pesso
is  desejos internos mas fora das
pressões da sociedade é que o
povo coreano é levado a acreditar pela indústria da beleza
que a única maneira de ser verdadeiramente
feliz é ser sua versão de
belo significado não se encaixar em seus
padrões é feio e consequentemente
infeliz na verdade toda essa ideia  que
beleza é igual a felicidade é o que mantém
as clínicas de cirurgia plástica funcionando e nos
negócios, incentivando-as a levar ainda mais
a ideia às vidas coreanas e aos
seguranças sobre sua aparência física  e
não são orgânicos ou gerados internamente,
mas sim criados por empresas que se
beneficiam financeiramente por
termos essas inseguranças esse é
o ciclo vicioso da estética da Coréia do Sul
é óbvio que as empresas de cosméticos e
clínicas de cirurgia plástica lucram com as
inseguranças e para isso precisam de nós
para se manterem inseguros, eles fazem isso
criando anúncios bem desenhados
e colocando-os em áreas densas e lentas
para que mais de nós sejam forçados a
olhar para eles por mais tempo, eles fazem isso
escolhendo celebridades que são idolatradas
pelo público mais jovem para serem as
porta-voz das clínicas de cirurgia plástica nós não
pensamos muito sobre isso achamos que não vai
chegar até nós já que em última análise somos nós
que estamos no comando dos nossos pensamentos
e opiniões mas como aconteceu
comigo aos oito anos pode acontecer com você
também
as ideias realmente o consomem
discretamente e muitas vezes você
nunca perceberá que foi consumido a
beleza significa felicidade e você não é
feliz porque não é bonito  iful e
você não é bonita porque você não
tem pálpebras duplas assim
agora você está insegura de suas monopálpebras
você acaba se convencendo de que essa
ideologia é um fato trabalhando a favor da
indústria da beleza e nós odiamos
desprezamos essa feiura  lado do nosso país
ainda continuamos alimentando continuamos
odiando nossa aparência continuamos olhando
duas vezes para os anúncios de cirurgia plástica
continuamos idolatrando os olhos grandes
continuamos alimentando o que nos prejudica esta
história não é tão distante não é dez
mil quatrocentos e  a trinta e oito
quilômetros de distância observamos os mesmos
problemas em cada uma de nossas
sociedades de países de origem, pode não ser tão
extremo quanto o caso da Coréia do Sul, mas
todos somos responsáveis como consumidores de sermos
os mensageiros que espalham essas idéias
que permitem que as indústrias acumulem mais
poder e influência  sobre nós,
seja a indústria do tabaco, a indústria do
álcool, a indústria da carne ou mesmo
a indústria da beleza, como na Coréia do Sul,
nosso papel consistente como mensageiros  é o
que permite que eles espalhem suas idéias
moldando nossa percepção do que leva a
uma vida feliz e satisfeita sua vida no
futuro pode se parecer com a sociedade sul-coreana
onde uma indústria redefiniu
o significado de felicidade onde uma
indústria sequestrou cada um
de nossos  fórmulas de felicidade individual
devemos acabar com isso devemos deixar de
ser os mensageiros todos podemos fazer
isso simplesmente começando a falar sobre isso
começar a reconhecer o fato de que estamos
colocando em risco a saúde de nossas sociedades
através de algumas das ideologias
que temos  decidiu adotar para alguns de nós
tudo o que precisamos é de um pequeno empurrão uma
discussão aparentemente pequena e insignificante
que desencadeará uma série de ações
que funcionarão para curar nossas sociedades e
impedir que as gerações futuras sejam engolidas
Coréia precisamos parar de
ouvi-las  a cirurgia plástica não é
necessária para você ser bonita não se
encaixar nos padrões deles não significa que
você não seja bonita a beleza não é o
componente chave  que impulsiona todos os outros a beleza
não é a chave para a felicidade nós, como
Sociedade Unida, devemos parar de espalhar e
acreditar nessas idéias que moldam nossas
fórmulas de felicidade contra nossa vontade a
saúde de nossas sociedades depende de nós
temos o poder de destruir ou curar em
última análise  devemos ser aqueles
que definem nosso significado de felicidade nossas
fórmulas individuais de felicidade são nossas
para formular e precisamos começar a
recuperar o que é nosso
obrigado
[Aplausos]